first of all we have our investment
methodology which is very strict
very process driven very research driven
and when you get to that point of
actually pulling the trigger on some
investments there are not too many
opportunities
right
[Music]
thank you for being on 20 minute leaders
how are you i'm good i'm wonderful thank
you very much from miami florida right
yes yes correct and while things may not
be looking up now by the time this is
aired it will go
better right yes a hundred percent a
hundred percent
right before this talk we discovered
that i have no idea what
uh what is what are the responsibilities
of running a family office
and and with managing uh managing wealth
of families so i'm very excited for this
chat and to learn as much as i can over
these 20 minutes
yeah i'll be happy to uh tell you what
we do
alone what is a family office let's
start from the basics because
it sounds like i just don't know um no
you were pretty close
um a family office is a family that
um service families that accumulated
uh wealth uh it's sometimes the first
generation
sometimes the second it could be the
third and even the fourth generation
that
holds that wealth what we do is
not only managing the wealth we also
service
them in other in other capacities as
advisors
is wealth planners helping them with
exits
helping them with estate taxes
and um also educating the next
generation about the wealth that they
accumulated
and wealth comes with a lot of
responsibility
oh hold on you you just like opened
pandora's box because you're basically
saying like you do everything
for the family because it sounds like
there's so many moving parts besides
educating the new generation
you know all of a sudden you have this
you have like an 18 year old who's now
adventuring into the world and
that has his or her family has wealth
and they want to be educated about that
you're saying you're also
helping them understand the taxes behind
their estates and
and and what you mentioned before which
was fascinating was
that you don't necessarily just look for
new opportunities to advance the wealth
but you're all you're mainly looking to
preserve the wealth
and how to do that responsibly right
right of course you have different types
of families and different types of
so if the you know the sun still is uh
at a young age he still wants to
accumulate
more wealth so you you might have
different um
objectives in different people but in
general
these people have accumulated a lot of
wealth at some point
what you want to do is take
the majority of that wealth and move it
and manage it in a way that you preserve
your capital you grow it by let's say
five percent
plus inflation or or something like that
but the most important thing is
you want to manage your risk you want to
stay in the game you want to don't have
you don't want to have drawdowns of 20
where this could actually change your
uh your way of life your standard of
living this is something you don't want
to happen
at this point you also want to focus
more about philanthropy a lot of them do
philanthropy
um uh early on but at some point you get
to the
to that stage where you can really make
a difference and they all want to do
that
okay and how do you even get to to be
and to run a family office so
you know what what path did you take in
life to get to the point where
you're you're reaching this where you're
doing this and you're excited about this
work
it's kind of boring i always did the
same thing
it's not i mean i finished my military
service i
joined the ministry of defense a little
bit and then i started
as working as a trader that was a very
long time ago
and he chose to go into family offices
instead of going to investment banking
instead of going to wall street i mean
you had a bunch of different options
right
right so prior to this uh position i uh
i managed an endowment
endowment is like the you know uh funds
that
yale runs uh harvard all these a lot of
stories about these type of funds
so i managed to fund uh like that for
nine years
uh and at some point when i decided to
move uh
to move forward i didn't want to go
i didn't want to go back to the old wall
street
i call it where there's a lot of
conflict of interest
it's all about the sales it's all about
the i wanted to be able to do the work
that i love which is mostly the research
um and uh you know i always tell people
of the work is the research 10 is the
actual investments
it takes time to get to that point where
you can pull the trigger
yeah you know i'm imagining you i'm
imagining you sitting in the office with
the fam like in the family office
managing the wealth and although you're
trading all day you're signing checks
and you're making transactions
i guess that's not the case no not at
all
we do a lot of work uh we speak to a lot
of people
uh in terms of the the research that we
do there are so many smart people in the
world
uh if it's either real estate it's
private equity venture
uh private debt you name it
um we wanna we wanna really drill down
into these type of
investments to understand where the
market is going
what should we be doing where are the
opportunities and where the risks
which is the most important thing right
and so
then you know you i guess do you work
with a family on understanding
what type of risk portfolio you want to
have is it high risk low risk what
type of investments you're more
comfortable with and then once you
decide together you move on to looking
at that vertical
and and narrowing down on the actual
investments
yes correct each uh each person each
family have their own
risk tolerance have their own objectives
have their own uh you know desires in
terms of again philanthropy or
uh um education of the
next generation so it's a little bit
different
but the truth is that first of all we
have our investment methodology
which is very strict very process driven
very research driven
and when you get to that point of
actually pulling the trigger on some
investments there are not too many
opportunities
right a lot of the stuff that you see
and you hear about it's
it's okay it's not great because we
invest in a more institutional
uh way we are very strict with the type
of investments that we're going to
do uh we institutional is
synonymous to low risk no not
necessarily
i don't mind taking risks as long as i'm
getting compensated for it
a lot of times you're gonna see deals
that have the high risk but the
compensation is not necessarily there so
that's something that we're not gonna
take
in terms of institutions i talk about i
mean the
management of the for example investment
fund
the the their ability of back office due
diligence
research we want to invest with people
that have done it a lot
a lot of time and the reality is that if
you look at
private equity venture the dispersion in
returns
between the top tier yeah and
the second one is so big that
i don't think you have the choice
as a as a wealth manager to be with the
second tier you want to stick to the top
ones now
not necessarily you're going to have the
access not necessarily you're not going
to have the ability to
but that's what we work for we use our
experience our relationships
our firepower to get into these
investments
so when when a family chooses the right
people to run their wealth
i guess in one thing that i i was one
thing i was thinking of course
was that your credibility and your
experience but
it sounds like your network and your
ability to get into the right
investments that's just as a critical
piece just like in venture capital
are we were as good as the deal flow
we're getting and if we don't have
access to the best deals
then it doesn't matter how good we are
and looking at
good at doing due diligence we're not
getting access to the best investments
yes but the first thing that you said is
the more important thing
first of all it's your credibility of
course they give you to manage
their wealth you become part of the
family
they have to be able to trust you
they'll be able to talk about that yeah
they want so that's the first thing
second
it's the access but also it's the way
that you
uh um it's everything together it's the
process it's the risk management it's
it's not just the best deals you can
have
access to a lot of deals if you don't
know how to put them together
you might have overlaps in different
areas in the portfolio and
when september 2020 comes everything
goes down together and that doesn't work
but getting access to the best deals is
definitely
extremely important it's not easy but
it's very important
and how do you build that trust with the
family because it sounds like
you know different from an investment
banker or wall street or venture capital
you're dealing with souls you're dealing
with people who are
putting their trust in you their you
know their hard-earned money
with you and how do you build that trust
is it you know over time do you apply to
it like a job application how does that
work
yeah it it takes time first of all this
business is all uh
word of mouth uh you get references from
uh
from from friends clients uh people that
think that you're doing a good job or
they think that you're a good person and
that's why
they refer other people to you uh then
it's uh it's a matter of time you really
have to earn the trust and it's not
something that they uh they do
lightly um there are a lot of things
that people are not aware of
that are going on in this market for
example
the whole conflict of interest in in
this business which is the worst thing
every time i'm about to ask a question
you bring it up before me it's
incredible
yes conflict of interest in managing
family wealth is it is it a big thing
is it hard is it like how do you even
avoid that
or how do you keep checks and balances
on that
you have to keep checks and balances
absolutely and we have our own
compliance officer that that
always goes and makes sure that
everybody is in compliance
but the reality is that look in every
and i'm not bashing here anybody or i'm
just just saying in in
the the model of of wall street and the
way that all the big
guys work the goldmans the mayorals
though
is that when they put you in an
investment
private equity private debt whatever it
is they're
getting compensated by the fund
not only by the client now what about if
the fund is not doing well are they
going to fire them
is the advice a hundred percent
non-biased it brings you to the point
where a lot of times
you create conflicts i'm not saying that
you know it's not a good fund or
but having that conflict by definition
is a problem
when you are compensated 100
by the family and only and you can
generate more money as a firm only if
they make more money so do you generally
is it generally a cut
of the profits or is it also or is it
more salary driven
no this this is uh and and this is one
of the things that's uh
very interesting about multi-family
office um
if you want to build your own family
office as a family
and you need a minimum wealth of between
half a billion and a billion dollars
because really
well you want to attract talent right
talent is expensive
if you run a startup you need to pay
your employees online because
then people like you who are
knowledgeable enough to make the right
investments right that's the thought
you're talking about
exactly and it's a team it's not one
person that can do it of course
but when we put a couple of families
together
they share the expenses and that's why
this model
works but even when they share the
expenses are those expenses
salary driven or or equity driven in the
profits
no no this is only a percentage of
the wealth that's being managed so if
you're not doing well obviously
your revenues are going to go down um
right but at the end of the day it's
it's
it's only one portion we we never had
an issue about the uh
the fees that we charge or or anything
like that
if you have an issue it's gonna be
something completely different because
this is not gonna make or break
your your uh investments right it's it's
something small
it's about how serious you take the
relationship
how dedicated the team is and how much
value you can add to the family because
you know with all the respect these are
families with a lot of resources
they can turn to almost any accountant
any attorney
any right what do you do better
can they be can they sleep
well at night knowing that you manage
all these
issues that's that's fascinating so you
know just like uh
you know an entrepreneur or ceo may have
ambitions to grow their startup from
you know a 10 million valuation to 100
million to a unicorn
do family offices or multi-family
offices have this ambition of
of you know reaching for the you know
the most
wealthy families both because then
they the percentage of the profits is
the greatest because
you're you know you have more assets
you're putting more you're investing
more
but also because of the status of it is
that how it works
it's the status it's more the challenge
uh
to be able to show that what you do is
really unique it's really that's what
all the ceos are saying come on
it's a look in any business that you do
unless you have um
an incentive right yeah
so it's it's it's all about that but
when you're able to put
of the incentives together right right
and then it works but you can't have the
conflicts the conflicts are just
at some point they're just gonna destroy
the the relationship
no no i'm sure i mean that's what it
sounds like it's and are these
long-term relationships or short-term
how how long does the average person
spend with the family
a very long term very long term um we
have
uh families that have been with us for
three generations
three generations generations so that's
a very long time
uh i like that you're counting it by
generations because essentially what
you're saying is that when a new
generation comes they have to decide
they almost have to decide whether
they're continuing to work with you or
they're going to
to others right very true so the
statistics is that
the second generation you have a 50-50
chance for them to stay with you
the third generation it's dropping to
single digits
right so if you didn't is that because
they have a conflict with their parents
and they want to
to go on a different path or because
they they know others or they feel like
they want to reinvent themselves
not necessarily it's it's uh uh i'll
give you an example
millennials they have different
objectives they have a different way of
seeing the world
they want to do things differently and
unless you can accommodate that
you know there's not the common language
it's it and it's a problem and that's
why we have younger people also working
with us
because they have to make that decision
once
the wealth is transferred if they gonna
stay with that person you have to do
that work well in advance explain to
them
and help them get to their to their
goals right they'll feel comfortable
they'll stay with you but if you don't
again the statistics is terrible wow and
so so what it sounds to me is that
what's really special here is that on
one hand you
have just as great as a responsibility
as if you're an investment banking i
would argue that you have even more
responsibility because you're dealing
with actual people
you know and these are relationships
that you're building but you have to
employ these
these interpersonal relationships and
skills to actually build
trust over time right this is not just
you know
a transactional relationship that will
change when you when you screw up but
when you screw up or when
when when markets follow some decisions
weren't the optimal
that interpersonal relationship you have
with them that's where that's where it
really counts right so that you continue
and you continue that work together
yes it's it's extremely personal um
i get to the point where you help with
the funeral arrangements
um it's wow it's uh
it's very very uh very deep of course
it's it's
as deep as the family wants to take it
but once they
they're able to trust you then then you
can do a lot of them
and uh you're happy to do that
interesting okay so what excites you
most about this job
what excites you most about about
running a multi-family family office
oh uh it's uh it's the the research
process
it's the ability to try and build that
puzzle
to understand how the world operates
because i haven't figured that
out yet um you're very independent in
doing that right because you don't have
you can basically uh you can offer
anything it's up to you you can
you can bring to the table any any ideas
i can yes the bringing the ideas is not
the problem
it's first of all you have to understand
the the big picture
right how the world operates the economy
the different
um cycles in the economy and once you
understand that they
then you know which type of investments
you want to bring into the table
a good investment by itself not it's not
necessarily a good idea
it doesn't mean that it's going to go
well with the rest of the investments
that you have
right sending the the the
economy the capital markets
that's the challenge that's the big deal
understanding that
some assets correlate over time but at
some point that correlation is going to
break and you cannot
trust that correlation to build your
portfolio
and we see that over and over again but
unless you have a process
and it's all process process process
you're going to miss that and you miss
that at the most important
critical it's point so interesting alone
before we leave what is one thing that i
can learn as you know a young
entrepreneur or a young you know i
let's say a young wealth manager of my
own i don't have much wealth
nothing at all but but i but i
nevertheless i do have to manage
whatever i do have
what can i learn from your experience in
managing
my own wealth as i go down the path of
life as an engineer as an entrepreneur
or you know as anything oh uh
i hope it's not gonna sound um bad but
uh i learned that what you study in
school is very different from the real
real world right the economy doesn't
operate like that
uh markets uh even companies don't
uh get yours your hands dirty
um kick the tires do the groundwork
learn how the
macro environment really works not
necessarily what you see
in you know supply and demand charts and
in school because it doesn't really
know about hindsight and you know
engineering and entrepreneurship is all
about
foresight so it's exactly like 100
100 i love it alone before we leave
three words that does describe you
only three words okay um
the important things in life then i'll
say
a husband a father yes friend
i love it and i love that none of the
three words are necessarily correlated
to the specific work that you're doing
and i think that speaks a lot about the
you know the personal nature of the work
that you're doing that you're not just
an economist you're not just
a financial advisor you are you're
you're relationship driven
and that's what guides it which i think
is wonderful it's all about
relationships it's not
work is work i love it
thank you very very much and thank you
very much
thank you very much thank you